If you want to make everyone obsessed with you
here's what you should do
this is highly effective because it works
This will make everyone enjoy your presence
have them running back for more
and when done correctly this has the
potential to deepen any connection
It’s so simple
it's as simple as repeating back to someone
what they just told you
you do this
and you instantly validate their emotions
and make them feel heard and seen
that's what anybody really wants
someone that actually listens to them
don't interrupt them with your own thoughts
simply just repeat back what they just told you
This also will just make you a better listener
let's face it
people love to feel validated
try this out if you want to create a deeper connection with anyone
Make them fall in love with you and obsessed
this is the lowest effort
highest reward conversation tip that you can use